das thema kausalität hatten wir in der
letzten sitzung gesehen ist ein durchaus
spannendes thema und der
qualitätsbegriff der kann durchaus auch
als normative angesehen werden also das
ist nicht ganz spannende frage ist
kausalität als übergang von ursache zu
wirkung also in diesem diesen übergang
liegt ja die kausalität
wir haben hier ursache ursache und
wirkung w dann haben wir eine relation
es geht hier irgendwie rüber und dieser
bogen hier den so eine gewisse
notwendigkeit hat der ist das spannend
also gibt es hier so eine summe netze
zitierende oder wie auch immer
auslösende kraft das ist das ganz
spannende thema ist es dann ist seine
kraft im spiel und theologisch gesehen
sicherlich wir haben gesehen ich
wiederhole noch mal als kommt den
meisten von ihnen jetzt sehr vertraut
vor
also wir hatten die frage gestellt was
für arten von entitäten ursachen und
wirkungen sind weil ich mache nur eine
kurze wiederholung wert von ihnen kann
nur noch ein paar kandidaten geben dafür
platz ursachen und wirkung sein könnten
arten von entitäten können sie nochmal
kurz mir so ein paar per zuruf listen
wir mal so ein paar kandidaten prozesse
genau sachverhalte richtig und der
klassiker ist natürlich der was würden
die meisten philosophen philosophen
sagen die ereignisse genau diese
ereignisse
jetzt habe ich ihn das letzte mal einen
artikel aus der standford encyclopedia
philosophy ausschnitten hier präsentiert
den ich ihnen sehr empfehlen kann den
sie im internet finden ich glaube dann
habe ich auch verlinkt mit einem der
zusammenfassung dieses seminar ist und
da wurde noch ein paar weitere mögliche
kandidaten für entitäten harten von
entitäten die
ursache und wirkung stehen können ich
würde nämlich features als eigenschaften
oder sowas
ich hatte selbst noch den kandidat einer
substanz ins spiel gebracht das ist
natürlich problematisch wie kann es
substanzen andere substanz verursachen
schwierig aber was doch in der substanz
gelegen ist ist etwas was unserer
intuition entgegen kommt dass wir wenn
wir es mit qualität zu tun haben zb mit
akteurs kausalität die wir von der bloße
ereignis kausalität unterscheiden müssen
dass im falle von akteurs kausalität es
mit substanz nichts zu tun hat mit
akteuren die die ursachen sind für
bestimmte wirkungen und der akteur ist
eine substanz eine substanz mit einer
gewissen potenz mit einem vermögen etwas
zu tun und durch das vermögen kann man
diese ursächlichkeit ziemlich gut
erklären aber so eine rede von
ereignissen kann dem weniger
entgegenkommen und ihm so eine rede von
tatsachen natürlich auch das ist viel zu
abstrakt als dass man diese kraft damit
noch fassen könnte
deswegen habe ich so ein bisschen
probleme hiervon nur von ereignissen zu
sprechen das finde ich ein bisschen zu
sehr sprach philosophisch orientiert das
ist ökologisch zu schwach die rede von
ereignissen aber darüber können wir
diskutieren wir werden jetzt im verlauf
dieses seminares ganz viele mögliche
kandidaten bekommen was für arten von
dingen von entitäten ursachen und
wirkung sein können dass die ökologische
frage und die logische frage die
betrifft hat ihr diese frage nach dem
übergang und hier kommen dann eben die
ganzen modalitäten endspiel also
notwendigkeit möglichkeiten hinreichend
nicht hinreichend solche dinge kommen
hier ein spiel und offen ist natürlich
die frage ob kausalität wirklich so
existiert oder ob kausalität nicht viel
mehr nur eine kategorie ist die wir als
lebensweltlich situiertes objekte die
wir überleben wollen in die natur hin
legen um uns einfach besser orientieren
zu können
nietzsche hat mal gesagt der mensch
erträgt alles wenn er nur weiß warum es
der fall ist und da ist was dran wir
sind einfach sehr befriedigt wenn wir
wissen das war der grund oder wenn wir
glauben zu wissen dass wir den kommt wir
suchen immer nach eine ursache
und dann sind wir irgendwie zufrieden
und es gibt nur wenige dinge die uns so
im unruhigen belassen wie eine offene
frage warum und wir wissen dass warum
nicht wir wollen einfach den grund
wissen dass es lebenswert ich intuitiv
völlig plausibel an könnte man sagen gut
liegt es einfach vielleicht nicht nur in
unserer evolutionären ausstattung dass
wir immer noch so was wie gründen suchen
gibt es die überhaupt oder sind es nicht
nur konstruktionen also kategorien die
wir hineinlegen in die welt die aber
eigentlich gar keine unlogische geltung
haben das ist also die frage nach der
objektivität von kausalität und in
diesem zusammenhang denk ich kann man
durchaus sagen und das betrifft jetzt
noch nicht die frage ob kausalität jetzt
objektiv wirklich unter logisch in der
welt vorliegt und nur subjektiv von der
interpretation der welt abhängen kann
man sagen dass kausalität wie mir
scheint doch ein schwach normativer
begriff ist das ist jetzt eine durchaus
starke these von mir ich bin als auch
erst seit einigen sitzung draufgekommen
seiner letzten sitzung in diesem
standort artikel wird der glaube ich
nicht darauf bezogen und das
kausalitäten normativer begriff sein
könnte mir scheint es ist ein normativer
begriff das heißt aber nicht dass er nur
subjektiv aber darüber sollten wir uns
mal gedanken machen ob man nicht eine
form von normativität im spieles wenn es
um qualität geht also wir haben ja eine
ökologische frage die betrifft die arten
der entitäten von ursache und wirkung
ereignisse prozesse situationen finde
ich ganz spannend die im vorschlag einer
situation die situation aber die ursache
von situation b denn was ist der vorteil
von situation ich glaube ich habe das
auch in der zusammenfassung kurz
geschrieben was spricht denn dafür
ursachen im sinne einer situation zu
sprechen
oder was ist der unterschied zwischen
einer situation mit losen ereignis
überlegen sie mal hier
[Musik]
genommen hat ist ein ensemble von
faktoren wie sie glaube ich richtig
sagen die eine ursache hervorrufen und
ob die eine wirkung hervorrufen ob die
wirkung jetzt wieder situation ist die
frage aber häufig würde man sagen ich
kann jetzt eine ursache gar nicht so
genau identifizieren ist jetzt diese
ursache dass all die frage nach der
individuellen der identifikation von
ursachen und da tut man sich häufig
leichter wenn man sagt es war ein
kontext zwar etwas solistisches zwar ein
zusammenhang von faktoren und dieser
zusammenhang war ursächlich für die
wirkung und dann kann man sich fragen ja
was gehört alles zu diesem zusammenhang
hinzu sind es notwendige bedingungen das
ist dass hinreichende bedingung dass
dann fängt es spannend an zu werden mit
dieser frage nach dem übergang der
modernität aber das ist auch nicht
glaube ich ein ganz guter kandidat eine
situation wird dann schwierig wenn wir
von akteuren sprechen die etwas bewirken
dass ich das man dann sagt das war jetzt
eine situation vielleicht müsste man
sagen ich war in der situation dass ich
das gemacht habe aber häufig würde man
doch er sagt ich habe einfach das
gemacht ich war der auslöser
sie sehen hier kommt die unterscheidung
zwischen akteurs kausalität und ereignis
kausalität wieder ein spiel das sind
zwei arten von kausalität und wir neigen
dazu kausalität immer das würde jetzt
mal behaupten an unserem handeln zu
messen als wir sind der stillschweigende
der unausgesprochenen master jeden
kausalen denkens wir als akteure und die
bloße ereignis kausalität da sitzt ein
blitz einschlägt und das brennen eines
hauses verursacht das ist davon nur
abgeleitet in einer gewissen weise also
ich glaube dass die akteurs kausalität
immer paradigmatisch ist vorbildlich ist
für die beschreibung von dingen
ereignissen der bild die man ereignis
kausal beschreiben würde
hat da müssen wir immer so ein bisschen
drauf schauen und ist jetzt die rede
hier von ereignis kausalität oder von
akteurs kausalität bei immanuel kant
finden wir ganz ganz prominent eine
fusion eine fusionierung von beiden
arten von qualität und zwar die
fundierung der ereignis kausalität in
der akteurs kausalitäten auf eine
gewisse weise also kann fungiert das
ganze in der subjektivität die aber
nicht mit beliebigkeit verkannt meint
sondern nur eine bedingung der
möglichkeit also eine subjektive
voraussetzung die aber gerade
objektivität generieren soll das wird
noch ein spannendes thema in einer der
nächsten sitzung will nur kurz ein
bisschen verrückt greifen die an der
letzten sitzung hatten wird dann uns
kurz sehr kurz mit platon beschäftigt
und hatten da eben kurz sein gleichnis
sein sonnen gleichnis uns angeschaut die
es in der schrift politik zu finden ist
in der politik im start und wir hatten
gesehen dass klar schon eigentlich gar
nicht so sehr interessiert für das
werden und entstehen dass kausale denkt
die kausalen prozesse die so hier auf
der welt vor sich gehen sondern er hatte
kausalität ihrem sinne der
ursächlichkeit verstanden also der
bildlichkeit der das ermöglichung des
grundes er hatten unterschieden zwischen
science grund und erkenntnis grund also
es muss einen grund dafür gibt dass die
dinge sind oder geworden sind und dass
wir sie erkennen können so wie sie sind
und ab fungiert für ihn dann
letztendlich in allerletzter konsequenz
die idee des guten dafür die jenseits
des seins ist sie also nicht sein das
ist wie es die ideen sind und hier kann
man glaube ich schon ziemlich gut sehen
dass platon kausalität oder
ursächlichkeit jedenfalls ganz stark
normativ ansetzt wenn er von der idee
dass guten sprich das ist natürlich die
quelle der normativität
ja beim besten wissen
zusammenfassungen von anfang an
zentralen begriff der text der die
qualitäten des jeweils in irdischen
körperliche seite wird april ist schon
sehr intensität index ist
genau wir hatten auch kurz das habe ich
jetzt nicht in der zusammenfassung
geschrieben wir hatten kurz das thema
behandelt dass platon eine komparative
ontologie vertreter platon kann ein ding
mehr oder weniger seiend sein das ist
uns heutigen total fremd wir sagen
entweder oder entweder existiert muss
oder nicht schwierig wird es zum
beispiel dann mit fiktiven charakteren
zum beispiel hamlet existiert hamlet das
ist eine spannende frage auch der
internationalität wie richten wir uns
auf fiktive personen
das kann man jetzt mal aus aber in einem
gewöhnlichen sinne existiert natürlich
der tisch genauso wie der stuhl und der
plattform ist es eben so dass er sagt es
gibt verschiedene stufen
am meisten existieren die dinge die
unveränderlich sind und die dinge die
den wandel unterworfen sind dies
existieren weniger und am allerwenigsten
existiert das böse und das schlechte das
ist für ihn etwas das böse was da was
ganz aus dem rahmen heraus fällt aus dem
raster ausfällt weil für ihn dass jenige
wachs existiert eben auch gut ist
letztendlich insofern es erkannt werden
kann
da wäre das stichwort die komparative
und theologien die mec access ist das
teilhaben an der idee also eben je
nachdem wie ein ding an der idee an der
jeweilige detail hat so sehr sehnt ist
das auch noch jetzt kann man sich fragen
ist die mit text ist die teilnahme
teilhabe eine kausale relation
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob man so
beschreiben soll
ich denke eher im sinne einer fundierung
also die ideen fundieren im sinne des
seins und das erkenntnis grundes in
verschiedenen einzel dinge aber worüber
wir häufig reden ist doch gerade das
werden und vergehen wir reden von
kausalität häufig so ein modus des
billard spielt das ist immer das
beispiel was mangel kann dann bringt
also wenn ich eine kugel anstoßen und
sie eine andere kugel kann in der
bewegung aus link das ist so ein focus
den plattform nicht interessiert an sie
hatten sehr sehr ontologisch und
normativ aufgeladenen ursachen begriff
ursache
im sinne auch das vorbild des paradigmas
paradigma das ist für ihn ganz wichtig
und deswegen glaube ich auch dass platon
nicht so ein geeigneter oder so ein
paradigmatische anknüpfungspunkt für
theorie der kausalität ist ich denke man
muss ihn behandeln sicherlich aber
eigentlich im wirklich heutigen sind
noch wirklich anknüpfung für eine
theorie der kausalität ist mir dieser
herr hier aristoteles und da ist seine
schrift physik sehr sehr wichtig ich
habe übrigens diese diesen text habe ich
auch in gänze den wir lesen hier kapitel
drei und vier kapitel 5 kam auch noch
ein bisschen mitlesen
den habe ich also auf viele festgestellt
und zwar aus einer sehr guten ausgabe
sehr gut lesbar jetzt nicht im
griechischen ich kann den griechischen
text auch noch drauf stellen aber sie
können also diesen text direkt aus
vehlow cast auch sich anschauen und wie
auch schon beim thema derzeit geht mir
noch ein seminar oder zeit immer
dienstags und auch da im zeit seminar
ist seine theorie aus der physik da ist
es dann aus dem vierten buch und hier
ist es jetzt als viertes buch kapitel 10
bis 15 und die theorie der kausalität
ist jetzt aus dem zweiten buch kapital
bis 4
vielleicht kapitel 5 ein bisschen und
jetzt wollen wir uns einfach mal diesen
text zu wenden und aristoteles ist nicht
leicht man redet ihr ganz schnell von
diesen vier ursachen form stoff wirkt
und ursache aber so leicht ist es da
mich das nur aufzuzählen wir wollen
jetzt zeit wissen text lesen unter drei
leitfragen also wie hängen die vier
arten von ursachen miteinander zusammen
und wie wirken die verursachen am
beispiel eines standbildes das ist so
dieses beispiel was er bringt und dann
kann man sich noch fragen wenn wir noch
zeit haben wie hängt kausalität und zum
fall miteinander zusammen er kommt am
ende noch auf dem zufall zu sprechen
schauen wir mal ob man da noch so weit
kommen deswegen jetzt die fragen und
jetzt können wir hier in diesem text
hinein gehen ich muss noch kurz zu
beginn sagen wenn sie dann mal diesen
text zitieren oder eine hausarbeit
drüber schreiben sollten zitieren sie
den immer nach dieser ausgabe also nach
dieser seiten zählung als 194 b und dann
im idealfall immer noch die zahlenangabe
also da müssen sie ihn halt den
griechischen text nehmen und zählen
welche zeile das dann nach dieser seite
wie es also zb 194 b 10
das wäre dann eben die zehnte zeile ab
beginn von 294 b es gibt immer a und b a
und b als praktisch 194 b
das nächstes dann mit 95 105 90 dann b
dann kommt 196 a und verwaltungsreform
und immer noch im idealfall zitieren mit
der zeilen zahlt weil immer zwischen a
und b so circa 20 zeile liegen dass man
einfach weiß wo ist es jetzt dazwischen
nur mal so als tipp muss man immer dazu
sagen dass sie den aristoteles gerne
zusätzlich noch nach dem zweiten teil
des buches zitieren können aber bitte
immer auch nach der nach der diese
paketierung von einem herrn müller ist
die glaub ich eingeführt worden
ok jetzt lassen wir einfach mal ein
bisschen den text ich lese vor nachdem
wir aber nun das bisherige festgestellt
haben müssen wir die erwägung über die
ursachen und die ursache ist die
schaltet man hin
tja habe ich praktisch altgriechisch
halb im deutschen geschrieben aber sie
können es lesen die ursachen anstellen
wie beschaffen und wie viele der zahl
nach sie sein denn da die untersuchungen
um das wissens willen ist wir aber ein
jedes nicht mehr zu wissen glauben als
bis wir das warum bei einem jeden
erfasst haben dies heißt aber eben die
erste ursache erfassen so ist klar dass
auch wird dieses im betrieb sowohl des
entstehens entstehen ist die genesis und
des vergehens stiftung als auch der
gemeine gesamten natürlichen
veränderungen tun müssen damit wir die
prinzipien wissen und dann auf dieselbe
nein jedes von dem was wir suchen
zurückzuführen versuchen ganz
interessant dass sie jetzt auch hier
sagt es geht immer um ein warum wir
brauchen immer eine antwort auf die
frage warum das es so diese diese
wirkliche frage die uns antreibt
man kann sich auch fragen wozu das kann
man sich auf fragen aber ich glaube die
wozu frage impliziert die warum frage
könnte man sich fragen wie verhalten
sich wozu und warum
wozu ist noch ein bisschen spezifischer
glaub ich wurde da ist der zweck
enthalten
der zweck enthält er immer ein warum
warum aber eben noch ein bisschen mehr
nämlich walter eine intention mit dem
spiel war und warum ein blitz hat
eingeschlagen da brauche ich keine
intention keine absicht zu unterstellen
jetzt hat einfach eingeschlagen ich kann
den physikalisch erklären wozu traurig
dazu nicht diese frage wird zu
wozu hat der blitz eingeschlagen um
jemand böses strafen das ist natürlich
immer so eine tendenz dann ereignis
kausalität im sinne der akteurs
kausalität zu deuten
das ist ganz klar das ist ein kategorien
fehler und da muss man also aufpassen
also sagt hier warum so es geht also um
die prinzipien um die arche ist das
prinzip dahinter ist die ursache und
prinzip als ursachen und prinzipien ok
jetzt geht es hier los jetzt gibt hier
eine sehr schöne unterscheidung und ich
habe jetzt jede form von kausalität
markiert mit einer ziffer also mariatal
center im eckigen klammern beginnt
gleich mit dem ersten nach einer
auffassung weise nun heißt ursache da
sie einige aus welchem als in ihm
enthalten etwas wird wie zb das ihr zur
sache der statue und das silber ursache
der trink schale und die höheren
gattungen dieser ist erst jetzt nach
einer anderen auffassung weise zweitens
aber die form und das muster als ursache
dies aber ist der wesens begriff und die
höheren gattungen selben wie zb von der
oktave ist die ursache das verhältnis
von 2 und 1 und allgemeiner die zahl
also die zahl ist die höhere gattung
eines verhältnisses und die bestandteile
des begriffs drittens werde heißt nur
sache dasjenige woher der erst die
anfang der veränderung oder der ruhe
ausgeht wie zum beispiel der ratgeber
ist ursache und der vater ursache des
kindes und überhaupt das bewirken die
ursache des birken und das ende des
veränderten viertens
fernen diesem sinne von endzweck diese
arbeit ist dasjenige um dessen willen
etwas ist wie zarte des tellers dass der
griechische begriff tellers wie zum
beispiel die ursache das spazierengehen
es ist die gesundheit
denn auch die frage warum geht er
spazieren antworten wir damit er gesund
bleibe und in dem wir dies sagen glauben
wir die ursache angegeben zu haben
naja gut man kann durchaus fragen darum
geht er spazieren
aber hier um die antwort damit zu
bekommen müssten eigentlich fragen nur
zu die den spazieren also wir können
sicherlich auch mit damit auf eine frage
warum antworten aber eigentlich scheint
mir ist hier mögliche frage die wozu
wozu geht denn der oder die jetzt da
spazieren ja um eben gesund zu bleiben
also etwas finalisten damit er gesund
bleibe und in dem wir dies sagen glauben
wir die ursache angegeben zu haben
gut wenn man jetzt nach oben im
weitesten sinne fast für alle möglichen
arten von kausalitäten dann geht es
natürlich als und gattungsbegriff warum
frage ist ein gattungsbegriff und die
wozu fragt ist eine art dieser gattung
konkreter fall von kausalität und denn
so bei allem war es nachdem ein anderes
die bewegung veranlasst hat noch
inzwischen vor dem endzweck geschieht
wie zb noch inzwischen vor der
gesundheit ist die schwächung der zu
üppigen säfte oder die aushandlung oder
die arznei oder die werkzeuge denn alles
dies ist um das m zweckes willen und
unterscheidet sich nur in soweit das
eine wirkung das andere werkzeuge sind
ungefähr also nun in so vielen
bedeutungen wird ursache gesagt das ist
jetzt zu dieser dieser logos clasicos
für die vier ursachen lernen und jetzt
können wir uns noch mal überlegen aber
sowas ist jetzt was von der sache wir
haben eben schon mal alle in der letzten
sitzung ganz am ende auf gezählt also
form stoff wirkt und zweck ursache sagen
worum geht's hier also was würden sie
sagen die nummer 1 was ist das eine
ursache
das ist vielleicht recht einfach genau
die matten material ursache die stoffe
also das jetzt oder das silber das ist
etwas aus welchen etwas wird
und zwar das sind ihnen enthalten ist
also in einer statue ist enthalten das
erz und daraus wird das ganze ja haben
sie damit probleme mit die einem solchen
verständnis von stoff ursache wir würden
ja heutzutage so was nicht mehr sagen
wenn wir jetzt diesen radiator diese
heizung betrachten hier dann würden wir
ja nicht sagen dass das metall oder was
auch immer das eisen die ursache dieses
radiator sex oder diese haltung was
würden sie sagen inwiefern kann man
davon im sinne eine ursache sprechen wie
finn ist der begriff der stoff ursache
sind voll
genau hier anders hin
antworten kann ich davon was man nicht
warum bezieht man versteht dass zwei
staaten hatten die eine ist aus stein
und dann zu fragen warum ist diese
platte oder warum ist die aussage dass
hier ist eine steinerne statue manchmal
warum wissen wie wichtig schlaf wurde
das was uns hier ist man in einem
welchem betrachtung aspekt des objektes
oder der aber könnte man das nicht auch
ohne den begriff der ursächlichkeit
klären sind einfach nur was für eine
eigenschaft hat ist aus was ist das okay
das interessant
[Musik]
eine ursache sprechen
grün okay sei
sie würden also sagen nicht hinreichend
aber notwendig jeden fall hinreichend
bist du noch etwas anderes hinzu kommen
damit sie möchten wir noch eine weitere
kausalität muss
als wenn der stein nicht wer wäre die
statue so wie sie ist nicht okay okay
sein dass das statur sein also wenn man
sagen würde sie meinen jetzt also sie
sprechen jetzt von der statue als
solchen
und sie sprechen von der konkreten
statue da diese da die individuellen
kann und man richtig tatsächlich ist
könnte man sagen so aus dem material
eine statue ist das ist ihr nicht
essenziell sondern das essentielle was
den status der statue macht ist die form
könnte man sagen wenn es jetzt um diese
konkrete start geht kann man natürlich
fragen wie kommt es dass sie so ist wie
sie ist und dann wäre natürlich einen
moment ihrer zeige ich einem antrag für
den anderen begriff an ihrer
konstitution ein schwieriger begriff den
wir hier aber mal ein spiel bringen
müssen konstitution fragezeichen
ihre konstitution also wie sie aufgebaut
ist ist dann ihre material beschafft hat
er würde material stoßen ursache sprache
würden das davonlaufen
er bringt dieses beispiel der buchstabe
und der silben erbringt das noch alles
tot ist willkommen da gleich noch auf
den einen der folgenden zitate konnte
auf dieses thema zu sprechen
also sehen hier gibt es verschiedene
ansichten könnte jetzt natürlich sagen
so eine statue kann man multiplizieren
wir können sie aus erz machen können sie
aus stein machen generell gesprochen
arbeit ist und die konkrete statue gibt
wie sie hier steht interessiert uns die
frage schon
[Musik]
wir sind wir irgendwie statuen
funktionalreform
das funktioniert nicht vor allen dingen
zum beispiel bei monitoren oder so dass
er
nicht nur finanziell sondern
es ändert sich auch dann und die frage
gegeben
irgendwas komplette wenig und schreiben
gesetz muss auch erschaffen könnt ihr
doch kein ergebnis eines prozesses sein
aber sieht die statue könnte jedenfalls
nicht existieren wenn sie nicht
irgendwie ne substanz hätte aus der sie
gemacht ist wenn sie nicht eine materie
hätte welcher art auch immer
das kann man ja sagen jetzt mal ganz
generell das also irgendetwas auch immer
die stoff ursache sein muss sei es jetzt
heißen sei es jetzt stein oder was auch
immer
aber es braucht eben eines dieser
momente man spricht dabei aristoteles
von dem sogenannten sünden holon ich
schreibe es manchen hallen und das heißt
so viel wie zusammen das schöne ist es
zusammen und das horn ist das ganze das
zusammen ganz so sagen und das sind
immer zwei momente ich sag jetzt nicht
dinge über die form die materie wo der
stoff und das sind zwei momente die das
ganze konstituieren form könnte man
sagen ist die idee oder die dass die
struktur oder wer auch immer oder die
die gestalt aber es braucht denn auch
etwas aus dem dann diese firmen
gewickelt oder in das die form hinein
gelegt wird
das kaufen wir heute enttäuscht
aufgenommen
[Musik]
genau also sehen also es ist irgendwie
doch wie gewisse notwendigkeit ist darin
jetzt wenn man einzelnen gegenstand
anschaut nur wir würden uns halt fragen
darauf möchte jetzt sprechen kommen wie
wirkt denn bitteschön der stoff in der
konkreten start
wie wirkt denn der wenn wir von ursachen
sprechen meinen wir auch immer ist etwas
von wirkung und ursächlichkeit anteil
wie kann denn jetzt bitteschön dieser
stein der wirken der wird doch gar nicht
der wird auch er bewirkt also der wird
doch so gemeißelt so bearbeitet in eine
form gebracht was am ende da die stadt
heraus kommt aber da ist doch der stein
und unserem verständnis nach nicht so
sehr das bewirken sondern das formel ich
jedenfalls bewirkte oder und dann sehen
später dann noch im folgenden jahr sagen
dass der standard ein bisschen
eigenschaften und dass wir ein bisschen
verlauten dass das erste wissen
spannender punkt da kommen aber noch
tragen auf diese wechselwirkung ich
behalte es noch im hinterkopf hatten sie
sich gemeldet
die idee war es im haben jetzt einen
status wie die freiheitsstatue
diesen möchte muss man ja wieder
gewonnen haben das ist das geld das man
sagt materialeigenschaften die dann auch
kausal in kausale erklärung mit
einfließen müssen als faktoren
das wäre durch also praktisch
eigenschaften die aber kausal relevant
sind im kausalen denken faktoren sind
das wäre möglich könnte
sein ziel ist es wohl bei das auch so
da europa kein verarbeitbarkeit das
heißt es ist
wir kommen auf die geeignetheit noch zu
sprechen wenn dann hier vom endzweck die
rede ist hier und das ist jetzt ein sehr
stark finales denken und bei platon ist
alles wie mir scheint immer final
durchwirkt durch die idee des guten
sie sind starke normativität die ist
auch in ganz dinglichen immer noch
vorhanden
art und weise dieser teil habe dieser
mit hex ist an der idee aber da haben
wir ganz stark diese dieses denken
dieses in eins fallen von kausalität
ursächlichkeit normativität
zweckmäßigkeit aristoteles macht jetzt
folgendes er dividiert diese dem
zusammenfall bei platow wo alles
zusammen film wo sein und sollen oder
sein und gut gutes fusioniert sind das
dividiert aristoteles auseinander
das ist analysiert er die einzelnen
elemente und dieses ganz stark normativ
im moment wäre dann eben ihr so dieser
endzweck wozu alles ist jetzt kann man
sich natürlich fragen diese
materialeigenschaften ihr beispiel der
freiheitsstatue wäre natürlich kausal
sicherlich relevant aber doch kausal
dann auch nur die fans wächst es zwecks
dass eben diese statue an dieser gegend
gebaut werden kann schließlich nicht aus
aber es hätte natürlich auch dann eine
eine eine gewisse implikation für den
endzweck
das also
[Musik]
das statt was sie dafür
genau die materie ist praktisch das
vermögen genau
und da wäre auch wieder eine kausale
dimension natürlich enthalten man sagt
der möglichkeit nach gut dass wir jetzt
nicht so ganz bestimmt die möglichkeit
man kann ja aus dem stoff alles mögliche
machen
aber die frage ist man könnte sagen wir
so eine potenziell potentia ist dahin
jetzt wäre die frage ob die potenzial ob
die auch noch auf eine gewisse weise
kausal verstand werden können als wir
haben hier die materie stoff ist die
möglichkeit und die form ist sagen die
wirklichkeit die form macht das ganze
konkret und der stoff ist erst noch
unbestimmt ja das kann man sich fragen
gut unserem verständnis nach wäre
natürlich die wirklichkeit stärker
karussell konnotierten das was etwas was
der bloßen möglichkeit nach existiert
wirklich ist nach unserem verständnis
irgendwie kausal relevanter als das was
nur möglich vorliegt da könnte man sagen
dass die potenz hat hat die potenz in
sich und wenn man von potenz spricht da
hat man auch schon so leichtes causales
denken impliziert ja
tanzen sind das umgekehrt sagt dann ist
dieses beispiel der freiheitsstatue bin
ich doch aus dem semantischen irgendwann
vielleicht eine stabilisierung gewesen
und diese stabilisierung der diesmal an
wir haben jetzt nicht nur den faktor dem
standort dass es eben jetzt viele insel
da die produktion dann haben die noch
dazu die investoren sowie das leben
schenken dann ist das ganze eher
transportiert es ist ja nicht nur diese
haltung in den stoff weil lernens
sondern der stopp ist ja auch schon
wieder eine beute der aus diesen ganzen
wirtschaftlichen aspekten also nichts
passiert dann wieder erst mal gegen eine
gewisse reife oder sagen das hier das
ist das ursächlich ist das grund dass
wir sind ja profis von heraufgesetzt zum
beispiel wenn ich jetzt sage ja hier wir
sind jetzt hier die frauen und ist geld
überwiesen
und wenn jetzt wahl der beiden ruft ist
die reihe zu gehen und auch erst dann
ist das ja auch das figur sinnlichkeit
von haus aus
richtig als ich mein was sie richtig
sagen ist diese vernetzung hört das also
sozusagen situation dass wir eben sehr
schlecht häufig nur einzelne faktoren
als ursachen identifizieren können
sondern häufig hängen eben die
verschiedenen ursachen miteinander
zusammen
dann ist sagen wir es preise und es ist
ja ist aus diesen schlauch verletzt
haben oder besser
wahrscheinlich weil dann notwendig
diesen stoff verwendet zu haben weil die
optimale lösung gewesen wäre ja also ich
glaube dass sie das richtig gesagt haben
dass es jetzt endlich ja immer auf
diesen endlich ankommen
und jetzt kann man sich natürlich fragen
warum führt aristoteles die vier
ursachen in dieser reihenfolge auf gibt
es dafür einen grund also jetzt mehr so
meine these oder vermutung mal es gibt
einen grund ist nicht willkürlich
schlechten sinne aufgelistet sondern
gibt es eine steigerung also da hätte ja
auch mit der wirkung sache beginnen
können oder mit der zur sache und es ist
jetzt ja so dass er hier also
tatsächlich eben erst mit der stoppuhr
sache beginnt dann geht er über zur form
oder zum muster ist das zweite dann geht
er über den sinn der ja bewirken ursache
also die causa effizienz die für uns
heutzutage die einzige eigentlich in der
naturwissenschaft geltende ursache ist
und dann ganz am schluss kommt er auf
die wirkung sache oder was er den
entwickelt des tellers dass taylors ich
kann es auch mal hin schreiben die
technologie der zweck
das ziel des tellers und jetzt kann man
sich natürlich fragen in welchem
verhältnis stehen diese verschiedenen
arten von ursachen zueinander also wie
würden sie sagen brauchen wir alle
ursachen oder gibt gibt es nicht die
möglichkeit nun mit einigen von diesen
ursachen etwas zu erklären warum steht
die ursache am ende
wir können anfangen damit dass wir
fragen wie verhält sich zweck ursache
und wirkung sache das ist vielleicht
riecht einfach das ganze wohl lieber aus
also dieses berichtes und songs von the
sun ist die ursache ist
nicht der realisierung als zum beispiel
er war ja also wir können ja bitte
[Musik]
er war ja material ursache anfang und am
schluss leben
ok na ja also das ganze sich so
aufschichtet zu sagen also dass man sagt
okay gut wir haben jetzt hier kopf heben
wenn man sich das mal genetisch es geht
mir das wert also ein prozess wir haben
jetzt hier stoff eisenerz
die kleine möglichkeit potenz und wir
haben die form
die form ist jetzt einfach kann man sich
vielleicht schon fast wirklich ganz
bildlich vorstellt die form sei jetzt
einfach die form in die das erz gegossen
wird das ist die form und dann was wir
haben diese zwei moment die komponenten
um ein individuelles dinge eine substanz
zu erzeugen einen süden holen und dann
stellt sich die frage ja wie wird das
jetzt realisiert offensichtlich so dass
da eine wirkung sache mit dem spiel
kommen muss also form und materie müssen
zusammengebracht werden
auf die weise der wirklichkeit ich muss
das eisen schmelzen und ich muss es in
die form gießen oder analog kann ich
sagen ich muss den stein so behauen dass
er dieser form entspricht dass er diese
form annimmt und dann wäre sagen das
letzte ziel dann habe ich eben jetzt
tatsächlich das zündholz erstellt und
dann wäre letztendlich die letzte
schritt wäre dann der wobei der
eigentlich schon im wird ursächlichen
angelegt ist wäre dann der zweck also
was mache ich jetzt damit ich meine die
die steht ja nicht da nur herum sondern
führt einen bestimmten zweck als sie
wird dann eingebunden in einen kontext
der kultur
sie dient als standbild in einem tempel
einen kulturellen ordner so kann man
sich das vorstellt hatten sie sich aber
erst
ich denke es geht um den beiden
richtungen also man kann
ich habe den zweck lassen dass die
mauern und ich muss ein stoff der tür
entwickeln und eine neue regierung und
somit die stadt wenn sie werde ich sie
draußen vom vortag
jetzt korrigiert ja ok oder es kann aber
auch anders total ist wieder einmal
stoffe zb
[Musik]
okay das war auch die anmerkung des
kommilitonen vor hin dass es da seine
wechselwirkung gibt ja als sie würden
dann damit sagen man muss nicht
unbedingt mit der materie ganz unten
beginnen so zu sagen ja weg erfordert
auch daneben eine bestimmte materie
gewissen stoff und der stoff gibt dann
auch vor was damit überhaupt theologisch
realisiert werden kann
wie sieht es aus aber auch wenn der fuß
ist nach funktion setzen sich menschen
die physis hat ja auch ihr tellers die
physis hat auch stellung der vogel baut
sein jetzt damit er sein nachwuchs seine
jungen darin eben pflegen kann also ich
glaube
aber ich denke bei aristoteles alles
letztendlich etwas belebt ist
theologisch strukturiert nicht so bei
der toten materie wenn denn aristoteles
überhaupt zu denken
er denkt er alles in dieser füßen und
flüssig ist es werden und stehen die
natur und da spielt natürlich das leben
eine große rolle und sobald wir es mit
lebewesen zu tun haben aber auch mit
pflanzen
es gibt ja diese seelen stufen und ganz
unten aristoteles hatte diese richtung
diese seelen schichtungen diese drei
stufen und alles beseelte ist für
aristoteles letztendlich theologischen
kontexten sagen wir mal unterworfen und
alles höhere stufe die seelische basiert
auf also drei stufen basiert auf
baslerin zehn stufen ganz unten ist
einfach nur eben diese seele stufe die
pflanzen betrifft diesen er sehe dass
der stoffwechsel ganz basalen sind dann
kommt in der nächsten stufe die
wahrnehmen der seele und dann als
nächster schritt kommt eben dann die
nuss und da gibt es eine differenzierte
unterscheidung von passiven und aktiven
us der nicht angelegt ist aber so das
ist ganz gestuft und das ist der
unterschied zum platon bei platon gibt
es in der sehen der nicht so eine stufe
von dir uns relation das also ganz basal
eine grundlegende dimension bei real
lebewesen angelegt sein muss als auch
der mensch braucht seinen eher seele
oder die kann er gar kein neues
entwickeln
bei planung haben wir ja wie sie alle
wissen diese dreiteilung der seele die
aber stärker hierarchisch aufgebaut ist
und nicht so sehr in einem schichten
modell ja also es ist nicht so dass
notwendigerweise jetzt das logistik on
das ist wird da sind höchst dass sie
enthalten das denkende dass das
notwendigerweise ein begehren des ep tw
con an begehrenden seelen teil unter
sich haben muss um überhaupt entstehen
zu können und auch kein team omd ist das
sind alles ihr lose wie mir scheint bloß
zählen teile die fast schon auch in
einer gewissen konkurrenz miteinander
stehen und auch
eine gewissen konflikt trächtigkeit
existiere und deswegen ein gutes
verhältnis gebracht werden müssen also
denkt das gar nicht alles tot ist denkt
es vielmehr fundierung mäßig geschichte
und nicht so sehr wie kleine akteure
platon denkt eigentlich die seelen teile
wie kleine subjekte und akteure die
miteinander kämpfer die vom höchsten
zählen zahlt den logistikern im zaum
gehalten werden müssen also eine ganz
andere vorstellung aber sobald wir es
mit belebten zu tun haben kommen nach
aristoteles die zweck ursache ins spiel
und wird es mir neigen heute dazu die
zweck ursache eigentlich nur noch auf
akteurs kausalität zu beziehen also
zwecke sind für uns eigentlich nur noch
dann wirklich und theologische
philosophische relevant wo es um
absichten geht um intention pläne geht
wir würden nie sagen der baum hat dann
intention
es ist sogar schon die frage ob tiere
über intentional i tät verfügen können
das ist höchst strittig ob tiere pläne
verfolgen können oder ob sie nicht nur
instinktiv handeln
wie dual bestehen seiner dienstlichen
tagen laufen die alte universal geben
könnte schlechter fahren
könnte man vielleicht aber da ich bin
jetzt kein biologie oder physik aber das
spielt eigentlich keine rolle meines
wissens also in der natur mit taylors
sohn zweck oder so nur ziel der der
natur also man spricht mit zwecken wenn
dann nur noch auf im sinne der akteurs
kausalität also wenn es um subjekte geht
die bewusst sind immer ein weg noch frei
sind
die konkrete zwecke verfolgen hatten sie
sonst noch bemerkungen zu dieser
richtung zu diesem verhältnis dieser
verursachen also ich denke schon das ist
ein grund hat warum er diese zweck
ursache ganz am ende hat aber wie wir
glaube ich auch gesehen haben es gibt
eben eine wechselwirkung zwischen den
einzelnen teilen
man kann das nicht so ganz streng
voneinander trennen jetzt lese ich mal
das nächste zitat vor
es ergibt sich aber da die ursachen in
mehreren bedeutung genommen werden dass
auch mehrere zugleich die ursache ein
und derselben ist und zwar nicht bloß je
nach vorkommen ist wie zb von der statue
ist sowohl die statuen bildende kunst
als auch dass er zur sache und zwar
nicht in irgendeiner anderen beziehung
sondern gerade ihn zu finden ist eine
statue ist aber nur nicht beide sind
gleicher weise sind das alle als stoff
das andere aber als dasjenige wovon die
bewegung ausklingen einiges ist auch
wechselseitig voneinander die ursache
wie zum beispiel das arbeiten ursache
des wohlverhaltens und dieses ursache
des arbeitens aber nicht beides in der
gleichen weise sind das eine als entzog
das andere als ursache der bewegung
aha spannend von welcher art von
kausalität spricht jetzt im ersten
beispiel von im sinne der das herz und
der statuen bildkunst statuen bildende
kunst ist eine zweite sache deine welt
ursache dieser beschreibung
für die eigentlich nur voraussetzung
sagen dass man ein tier nimmt und wir
tun das nicht
wir können auch sagen gründe wir können
auch versuchen es mit grund zu
reformieren und dann wird eben im sind
dem material ursache einfacher zu
verstehen
eine statue hat einen materiellen grund
fast schon im wörtlichen sinne
sie steht auf etwas das sie besteht
besteht aus einem materiellen grund aber
hier spricht er jetzt ja nicht nur
ökologisch von 1 grüne zone er spricht
ja auch immer sie im sinne von eine
relationale tätern zweistelligen
relation er sagt es ist ursache des
anderen von etwas anspricht in diesem
sinne des übergangs von ursache und
wirkung
und wir sprechen häufig von wenn wir von
theologisch von gründen sprechen nicht
unbedingt im sinne von zweistellige
relationen erscheinen das ist einfach
der grund das existiert aber der bewirkt
jetzt nicht direkt fassen diesem sinne
und hier scheint er doch so ein bisschen
wenn er verspricht mir dieses ursache
wirkungs verhältnis auch im sinn zu
haben
aber noch mal zurück auf die frage was
ist start um bildende kunst ich hätte
jetzt abtreten prima fazit gesagt das
ist die zweck ursache aber es ist es
nicht sondern es ist dasjenige wovon die
bewegung ausgehen
die statuen bildende kunst ist
offensichtlich
ich mich nicht irre die wirkung sache
hier und nicht die zweck ursachen ist
ganz interessant so und jetzt sagte also
hier das also die tatsächliche entsteht
als die statue das objekt das die könnte
man sagen kausal über determiniert ist
oder kausal an determiniert ist also da
gibt es verschiedene ursachen die
letztendlich die statue wirken und die
zusammen sie konzentrieren
aber eben nicht auf die gleiche weise
sondern einer anderen beziehung
wie verstehen sie jetzt das zweite
beispiel wo er sagt dass das arbeiten
ursache des wohlverhaltens also das wohl
science ist
verstehen sie das
[Musik]
richtig aber wie verstehen sie jetzt
hier dieses beispiel des arbeitens und
des wohlverhaltens wie kann man das
jetzt auflösen im sinne dieses dieses
diese wechselwirkung gut das wäre eine
möglichkeit
das wäre eine möglichkeit ist aufzulösen
haben sie sonst und vorschlag müsste man
rein schauen vielleicht haben es ich
habe in den text fischer also auch
nachschauen
das gut sich verhaltens des
wohlbefindens und vielleicht auch sein
wohlbefinden
könnte es sein hier können sie mal
reinschauen das ist 105 90 kann kann ich
auch sonst nachliefern
ich habe ihn den textern
deutsch-griechischen rom geschickt
also ist also eine möglichkeit also wir
können nur dann arbeiten wenn es uns gut
geht und das arbeiten selbst trägt auch
zum wohlbefinden bei das wäre eine
möglichkeit
und hier werden jetzt in diesem zweiten
fall
ja wohlbefinden wohlbefinden haben
m
[Musik]
und es ist eben auch der grund dafür
dass überhaupt arbeiten können also hier
gibt es diese wechselwirkungen wie der
kommilitone glaube ich sehr treffend
gesagt hat so und jetzt haben sie es das
griechische wort borussia wäre die
anwesendheit
immer also es lohnt sich eben auch in
den griechischen text zu schauen wenn
man den altgriechisch des
altgriechischen mächtig ist und jetzt
lesen wir weiter jetzt kommen nämlich
diese vier ursachen noch mal in einem
neuen kontexten werden aber beschrieben
und ich hab hier wieder die ursachen am
nummeriert erstens zweitens habe ich das
auch ja hier zweitens hier drittens und
viertens als jetzt lese ich das auch mal
vor jetzt schauen wir mal wie er jetzt
in diesem zitat hier
diese verursachen sich noch mal
konkreter vorstellen also er sagt ferne
ist ein und derselbe ursache des gegen
gesetzten denn was durch seine
anwesenheit ursache dieses stimmten
dinges ist das geben wir zuweilen bei
seiner abwesenheit als ursache des
entgegengesetzten an wie zum beispiel
die abwesenheit des steuermanns die
ursache des umschlages des fahrzeuges
während die anwesenheit des selben und
sache die unversehrtheit des fahrzeuges
war die gesamten zu eben angegebenen
ursachen aber fallen unter vier klassen
als die augen felix erstes nämlich wenn
die buchstaben das ist jetzt dieses
beispiel in die buchstaben ursachen der
silbe sind und der stoff ursache des aus
dem zubereiteten und das feuer und
dergleichen ursache der körper und die
teile ursachen des ganzen und die
prämisse ursachen des schlusssatzes so
ist da überall ursache als dasjenige
voraus etwas wird zunehmen
zweitens hierbei aber eben ist eines
ursache als das zugrundeliegende wie zb
die teile und ein assist ursache als das
wesentliches seien nämlich das ganze und
die zusammenfügung und die form
drittens hingegen der samen und der arzt
und der ratgeber und überhaupt das
bewirken
dieses nämlich ist ursache als dasjenige
woher der anfang der veränderung oder
des stillstandes oder der bewegung
ausgehen endlich wieder anderes ist
ursache als der endzweck übrigen und
dessen gutes
dem dasjenige mit dessen willen etwas
wird will das beste und der endzweck das
übrigen seien dabei aber möge ist kein
unterschied machen ob wir von einer idee
des guten oder von einem erscheinenden
guten sprechen das ist jetzt gegen
plateau befindet
dieses als und und derart nach so viele
sind die ursachen oh jetzt müssen wir
versuchen dass hier ein bisschen besser
zu verstehen
hier kamen jetzt einige begriffe wie
davor also zb so was wie bei punkt 4
hier der endzweck das ist schon mal ganz
klar aber wie verstehen sie die anderen
punkte jetzt haben sie die wie kann man
daraus jetzt etwas in schüpfen
auch schon geschehen ist nicht einfach
also das ganze thema schreibt der roman
war
die man bei uns machen wollten das thema
familie alles was dein ist eine form und
als das einkaufscenter zu verteidigen
das hat das
und 5
die lupe zu nehmen
die intensität ist in jedem sein können
und was er vorher
vielleicht weiß sind unter gleichen
dienst ist allerdings klein ist
genau ob es qualitäten sind ist die
frage aber jedenfalls man kann ja sagen
ursachen ein guter punkt wenn du jetzt
aber mal dass in holland betrachten
können wir wieder sagen dass jetzt die
statue aus erz oder aus stein die
konkrete starten
da müssen wir fragen aber wie hier genau
die verschiedenen kap die verschiedenen
ursachen oder faktoren kausalen faktoren
hier einfluss nehmen also wir haben die
form und die materie die
zusammengebracht
sie können in meinen augen das wird
meine these nur insofern
zusammengebracht werden form und
material mit 1 einzelnen entsteht indem
wir wirklich handeln
genau gar kein gegensatz
genau als ich stimme dir vollkommen zu
also hier wäre es zu sagen die relation
und das relation ihren zwischen form und
materie wäre die wirklichkeit oder die
am ding am konkreten dingen nach
nächsten mails und die haben es vor
materie
daraus würden wir das hier etwas nicht
weil das vom moment
ja also in einer gewissen weise
existieren sie schon aber modal eben
verschieden also man darf sich jetzt
form und materie nicht so vorstellen als
ob sie jetzt wie dinge oder individuen
existierten also materie ist ja erstmal
nicht individuell
das ist wie wenn wir im französischen
der sprachgebrauch wenn wir sagen ich
hätte gerne käse naja es ist nur fromage
also dieses oder vom weinen genauso
das ist also ein masse nomen das ist
liegt also nicht individuell wenn ich
sage ich hätte gerne ein stift natürlich
ein stift aber ich hätte gern einen käse
ein stück käse ich gerne aber dann ist
das stück habe ich hätte gerne vom käse
aber es ist jedenfalls nicht individuell
und genauso ist das problem wie die
formen existieren soll sie gleich einen
moment sie liegt nicht vor individuen
wie es dann die statue ist aber sehen
natürlich ontologisch beide formen und
materie relevante signifikanten aber im
sinne der existenz eines individuums
definitions natürlich nicht denken dass
wir bringen sie zusammen damit sie etwas
individuelles konstituieren können dort
bilden können und hier und darauf kommt
es jetzt an um sie überhaupt zusammen zu
bringen
hier muss dann die wirklichkeit hinzu
kommen als die wirklichkeit ist nicht
auf dem erscheinen des militärs jetzt
ist nicht auf derselben ebene
angesiedelt wie es vorm ursachen stoff
ursache ist sind irgendwie auf einer
höheren ebene
damit nehmen weil sie nämlich beide
zusammen bringt das wäre es meine thesen
und damit gibt es ergibt sich schon eine
gewisse hierarchie weil der stoff liegt
letztendlich völlig generell und in
different vor als bloßes vermögen und er
wird realisiert durch die form natürlich
realisiert durch das zusammenbringen der
form oder das herantragen davon an die
an die materie
aber ich glaube hier gibt's schon
gewissen prozess der stoff wie vor geben
das herz liegt vor und würde natürlich
war dass die tatsächliche bürgersaal
irgendwie schon vor das heißt der
meisten
ist genauso gegeben irgendwie das erstes
gewinns stofflichkeit übersichtlichkeit
ist also es ist nicht das gleiche
die stoffe waren ursache genau ich
glaube der gute unterscheidung genau
also betrachten wir jetzt die
verschiedenen kausalen faktoren sage
jetzt mal die ursachen im sinne ihrer
gattung art im sinne ihrer begriffliche
ihres begrifflichen gehalts da glaube
ich schon dass wir da so eine gewisse
logik entdecken können
die sonne gewissen aufbauende gewisse
schichtungen und wonach doch tatsächlich
am ende diese zwecke sachlich zeit
stehen soll wie ich komme gleich auf sie
zu sprechen aber jetzt genau weiter
jetzt haben nämlich erst drei kausale
relationen oder faktoren gesprochen
die möglichkeit die wirklichkeit die zum
südholland gebildet werden durch
wirklichkeiten jetzt stellte die frage
ja und wo kommt dann in diesem bild
bitteschön dann die zweck ursächlichkeit
spiel haben sie eine idee wie wir die
auch noch hier einbringen können damit
sich diese schichtung und diese logik
dieser kategorien noch schließt könnte
man das denn dann machen wir haben sie
nicht
ganz genau das wäre darin ist sowas mit
mehr oder weniger dann der ganze sind
die ganze bedeutung der zweck wozu diese
statue dann dient in ihrem
lebenswichtigen kontext also ich glaube
schon dass man das so rekonstruieren
kann beginnend mit dem stoff dann mit
der form die aber noch nicht wirklich
individuell existieren dann muss es
zusammengebracht werden
da kommt dann die wirklichkeiten spiel
und wenn es zusammen gebracht wird dann
wird der sinn des ganzen und der zweck
des ganzen auch verständlich sommer zwei
meldung erst sie und dann hier
[Musik]
also gehen wir noch mal ganz kurz zurück
hier hat er bei diesem ersten bei dieser
ersten auflistung hatte er hatte er die
form und das muster gebracht form und
das muster form und musste
er unterscheidet hier form also
unterscheidet diese diese vorsicht
lichkeit in form und muster und ich
denke dass er eher die oktave als ein
muster verstehen würde
oder zumindest als eine relation ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das in diesem sinne
dieser form dem klassischen sinn machen
würde weil er doch dann auch das
standbild immer bringt als beispiel
und ich glaube schon dass man sich die
form sehr konkret vorstellen kann wie
eine form einer statue war natürlich hat
auch eine oktav eine form eine gewisse
das aber dann eher so eine relation oder
sonne so ein logisches musste nun ein
verhältnis genau
und da kommt dann natürlich da ist da
stellt sich dann die frage wo kommt denn
da die materien spiel man könnte sagen
dass gut die töne oder die frequenz die
die konkrete frequenz da ja genau das
die physikalische realisierte frequenz
und dann wäre eben die die form wäre das
verhältnis aber hier kann man dann bei
einem meiner tafel nur noch schwer
konsums in holland sprechen da bin ich
mir nicht sicher inwiefern eine oktav
für diese dieses verhältnis inwiefern
dessen symbol und ist ein gutes hat eine
gewisse materiale seite ist der schal
oder die frequenz dass das könnte man
als eine materie bezeichnen und die
verhältnisse könnte man als die form
bezeichnen ok als einen zweiklang geben
im sinne der und hafen wäre möglich aber
ich glaube das schließt nicht aus dass
wir eben doch ganz wörtlich form auch
verstehen können wie die form einer
statue
es wäre eine abstraktere worden
aber jetzt haben erst hinein als ich
meine natürlich kann man auch sagen eine
statue ist auch etwas was mit
proportionen zu tun hatten eine start
und form sind auch proportionen
ich kann nur dann sagen es ist eine
menschliche statue wenn sie die
proportionen eines menschen hat also
wenn eben der oberkörper zum unterkörper
sich einen gewissen verhältnis befindet
wenn jetzt der oberkörper dreimal so
lang wäre wieder unterkörper dann wäre
das kein mensch
den viktorianischen menschen kennen sie
alle den viktorianischen man das ist
dieser mann der da seine arme ausstreckt
und die beide ausstreckt und dann ist da
soll kreis drumherum gemalt und das
natürlich alles proportionen auch also
ich gebe ihnen recht man kann versuchen
form auch im sinne von pro portion oder
relation zu fassen kann man auf eine
sehr komplexe weise durch denke ich auch
tun
jetzt hatten sie sich gemeldet und dann
zusätzlichkeit die gehen auch in dieses
muster werden verschiedenen halt hier
ein festes system
das chinesische programm passen das dann
wie drinnen steckt und ob jetzt der
lebenskraft ist und mit professionalität
baumkronen und alt dass ich sehr wohl
sache mit der materie sache hier
unmittelbar versöhnen wollen auch seine
mutter bringen weil also
ich sagte also bei aristoteles ist alles
was belebt ist seelisch verfasst und
alles was seelisch verfasst hat hat
prinzipiell dieses terrors in sich und
deswegen kann man das auch mit mehr
kastanien machen wir mit allem was eben
pflanzen angehört
bei stein wird es schwieriger bei
steinen kümmern oder bei solchen
naturereignissen wird es schwierig da so
eine final ursache einzubeziehen
dann wird auch schwierig es gut
wirklichkeit geht schon ihr aber diese
zweck ursächlichkeit ist jedenfalls noch
im heutigen verständnis sehr schwierig
werden wir uns kastanien durchaus in
einem sehr landläufigen sinne als
theologisch also zweckmäßig fast
vorstellen können ja jetzt hatten sie
sich
[Musik]
und im text steht hier verstehe ich auch
so mit vor mache das was wirklich ist
und die gattung davon genau dem beben
mit diesem umlauf bleiben mit diesem
verhalten genau also dass er sagt wir
können also die die gattung ist
natürlich noch abstrakter als die art
wenn ich jetzt sage ich habe ein tier
das ist jetzt auch mal müde oder ist er
ziemlich konkret bestimmte löwen ist
eine art begriff ich kann aber auch
natürlich sagen es ist ein lebewesen
wenn säugetier bin ich auf gestiegen auf
eine höhere allgemeinere ebene
es hat mir immer so konkret ich habe
dann nur noch relation und ich kann
sagen dass säugetiere ist eben definiert
durch bestimmte grundsätzliche
eigenschaften main wegen weitesten sinne
relationen und ich glaube auch dass es
so sieht also diese ob tafel ist eine
abstrahierte form dass eine relation
aber kann natürlich wie sie es versucht
haben zu zeigen und das war auch mein
punkt man kann versuchen dann über die
nationalität zu formen zu gelangen dass
man sagt meine form ist eine ganz
komplexe komplexes verhältnis ganz
komplexe relation kann man durchaus so
also das verhält sich so zu also eher
mit der kopf verhält sich wie jetzt der
viktorianische man von leonardo da vinci
tut also der kopf steht in diesem
verhältnis zum oberkörper der oberkörper
diesen fällen ist unterkörper die beine
und die arme ausgestreckt sind genauso
lange wie die distanz vom scheitel bis
zur sohle
solche sachen dann kann man auch sagen
wenn wir nur genug relationen angeben
ganz ganz große anzahl von relationen
die eine einheit bringen dann haben wir
darüber die form bestimmt genauso können
sich das vorstellen wenn wir
mathematischen form geschrieben im
mathematischen sinne von relation
kriege ich am ende auch eine form raus
oder wenn ich über eine funktion wenn
ich über eine funktion grafen zeichnen
im koordinatensystem habe ich auch nur
relationen angegeben sind oder
abhängigkeitsverhältnisse funktionen die
am ende wenn wir das einsetzen einen
schönen grafenegg ich denke so kann man
sich das auch vorstellen ist halt die
abstraktere ordnen
ok jetzt lesen wir noch mal eins weiter
als er sagt die auffassung weisen aber
der ursachen sind der zahl nach zwar
viele bringt man sie aber unter die
hauptsächlichen sind sie auch sind auch
sie weniger
es wird nämlich ursache in vielen
bedeutungen gesagt und zwar selbst von
den ursachen gleiche art die einen
ursprünglichen oder abgeleiteten sinn
als die andere wie zb als ursache der
aggression teilt der arzt und der
künstler und als ursache der oktave das
doppelte unterzahl und so immer die
umfassenderen ober arten im vergleich
mit dem einzelnen ferner auch die uhr
wird kleiner auch wird ursache in dem
sinne des bloß je vorkommenden oder
seiner höheren gattung genommen wie zb
ursache der statue ist zum anderen sinne
politikers und in anderen staaten für
fertige weil es für den staat unfertiger
nur ein je vorkommendes ist dass er eben
politikers ist und so wieder die
umfassenderen objektarten tc
vorkommenden wie zb wenn man sagte der
mensch oder gleich allgemein ein
lebendes wesen zur sache der statue aber
auch von dem klo sie vorkommen liegt
dass eine entfernte oder nähe oder das
andere als es andere wie zum beispiel
wenn der weise und wenn der gebildete
ursache der statue genannt würde ganz
schön kompliziert aber sie haben sich
gemeldet dazu
es ist schon irgendwie die antwort auch
die diskussion nämlich dass man
sozusagen von der vorderseite stellen
kann so dass praktisch anzuwenden und
kann die magnetischen in diese
kategorien aufgeteilt und dass man dann
sagen wir natürlich ist bei dieser
menschen jede stadt oder stein hat die
professionalität und die menschliche ich
kenne keine formulare genau sind
eigentlich vor mehreren das ist nicht
meins ist sie nicht zur verschiedene
dinge
solche figur soll und wenn man dann
redet dass sie betrogen hatte
dass sie eine menschliche form das ist
zwei mal genauer an
sie hatten sich dazu noch gemeint warum
ihr die konkreten wege
aber eine statue statuen und so
menschen diese das hatten wir jetzt auch
eine diskussion davor schon immer mal
wieder gehabt auf welcher ebene reden
wir reden wir hier auf der allgemeinen
ebene auf der begrifflichen ebene von
ursachen wirkung oder reden wir von der
konkreten bewölkung der konkreten statue
[Musik]
genau und das ist dann letztendlich auch
dass totti haben sie das schon mal
gehört von aristoteles dass es so zu
sein könnte auch sagen schreib sind
griechische dieses da dieses was
eigentlich tolle tief also dass dieses
was es ist also nicht nur das war's das
wäre die allgemeine ebene sondern dass
dieses war also dass das schön holland
wobei das in holland ist natürlich auch
noch was also ist auch noch dieses
allgemeine das eben ein ding ein
gegenstand sich zusammensetzt aus vor
materie aber es gibt das diese stars
also das konkret bestimmte individuum
das sich gemäß der in holland
zusammenfügung
[Musik]
was gemäss dieser zusammenfügung
existieren also ist eine wichtige
unterscheidung des nennt aristoteles das
tutorial dass dieses war's also ich
finde ich ganz treffend wobei natürlich
das problem ist auch wenn wir über das
dieses war es sprechen sprechen wir von
diesem individuum immer in allgemeinen
begriffen
wir haben keine sprache um etwas
wirklich individuelles als individuelles
zu bezeichnen sondern indem wir es
bezeichnen indem es behandeln bringen
wir es immer wieder unter allgemein
begriffe
gute ja das ist richtig aber ist ein
eigenname und kein begriff also
politikers ist kein begriff
das ist ein eigenheim richtig das ist so
eine richtige bezeichnung sowas in
mexikanische schon fast aber das ist
glaube ich noch ein wichtiger punkt okay
ist wenn wir weiter ob wir noch ein
bisschen schlauer werden aber das sind
schon sehr schwierige zitate alle
ursache aber sowohl die ihn eigentlich
im sinne genommen als auch die in dem
sinne des blue sea vorkommenden wird
wieder teils als potenziell teils als
aktuell genommen wie zb ursache erbauung
eines hauses ist sind wieder der
häuserbauer überhaupt oder der eben ein
haus brandl häuserbauer auf gleicher
weise aber mit dem eben gesagten kann
man es auch bei den dingen deren
ursachen die ursachen sind genommen
werden wie zb die ursache entweder
dieser bestimmten statue oder einer
anderen stadt überhaupt oder gleich
allgemein einer bildlichen darstellung
ursache dieses stimmte nerz ist wohl
dass ihr das haupt oder gleich allgemein
des stoffes und ebenso bei dem closely
vorkommt und ferner kann auch jedes von
diesen beiden nämlich sowohl dies soeben
bemerkt als auch jenes vorhin gesagt in
einer verbindung mehrerer genommen
werden wie zum beispiel wenn man bei dem
obigen nicht politikers allein und nicht
statuen verfertigte nein sagt sondern
politikers der statuen für fertiger das
ist auch ein schwieriges zitat sind sie
daraus schlau geworden haben sie da noch
einen punkt gefunden der noch in unsere
diskussion passt
ja
genau also teils als potenziell teils
als aktuar aktuellen also hier der bau
eines hauses entweder die ursache der
erbauung eines hauses ist entweder der
häuserbauer überhaupt wurde eben ein
haus bauen der häuserbauer als ein
konkreter häuserbauer einer bestimmten
statue dieser bestimmten statue das ist
das tolle team dieser bestimmten status
oder einer stadt gebaut
das ist ein wichtige unterscheidung
glaube wir ich lese noch einiges vor
und dann macht man schlüssel angeblich
einen kurzen blick auf die nächste
sitzung das jetzt noch längere zeit hat
aber doch ist alles dieses der zahl nach
nur 63
jedes aber dabei in doppelter bedeutung
nämlich entweder ist es dass einzelne
hre oder es ist die höhere gatte oder es
ist als das bloße vorkommende genommen
oder als die höhere gattungen dass sie
vorkommenden in einer verbindung
mehrerer oder jedes einfach für sich
genommen und dann als dieses wieder
entweder im aktuellen oder im
potenzielle im sinne genommen dabei aber
ist der unterschied dass das aktuelle
und einzelne immer zugleich mit
demjenigen dessen ursache es ist
existiert und nicht existiert wie zb
dieser bestimmte soeben highland harz
ist zugleich mit diesen bestimmten
genießen denn und dieser bestimmte eben
ein haus bauen de ist zugleich mit
diesen bestimmten im baur begriffen
hausen bei dem potenziell hingegen ist
dies nicht immer der fall
denn das haus und erbauer vergehen nicht
zugleich aber man muss von einem jeden
wie auch bei allen übrigen die äußerste
ursache suchen wie zum beispiel der
mensch baut ein haus weil er häuserbauer
ist der häuserbauer aber ist dass
infolge der hausbau kunst die es also
ist die ursprüngliche ursache und so bei
allen
ferner sind die höheren gattin ursachen
der höheren gattungen hingegen dass
einzelne dass einzelne ursache des
einzelnen wird zum beispiel statuen für
fertige überhaupt ist ursache der statue
überhaupt hingegen diese bestimmte ist
ursache dieser bestimmten und das
potenzielle ist ursache des möglichen
hingegen das aktuelle ist nur sache in
bezug auf das wirklich ins werk gesetzt
von vielen ursachen also und nach welche
auffassung weise ursachen seien das möge
nun von uns hinreichend festgestellt
sagt wie das war ein langes detail eine
schwierige zitat aber würde mir einfach
nur mal hier vielleicht auch nicht die
beste übersetzung ich habe ja noch eine
andere gegeben die ihr mit dem
griechischen text ist glaube ich ein
bisschen besser sie könnte auch nur
parallel reinschauen das war halt die
text will am besten portier bahre
version auf folien kopierbare version
aber was ist jetzt hier soll man die
aussage nochmal was uns geht es jetzt um
verschiedene ebenen der unterschied
wir hatten jetzt schon mal einmal so
diese ebene zwischen dem konkreten
dingen und seinen kausalitäten und die
begrifflichen oder allgemein dingen was
sagte jetzt hier was kann jetzt die
ursache von einander sein und was nicht
gerade im unteren teil noch ein bisschen
mehr davon hören gattungen einzelnen
gattungen spricht wir von ihnen kann das
noch mal kurz zusammenfassen was sie
jetzt damit sagen möchte
das konnten wir die ursachen zurück
das hatte öffentlich
also es muss immer auf derselben ebene
bleiben
aus sagt förderung ist dass sie das was
wir doch eigentlich einander sei wichtig
aber es gibt das prinzip möglich
dann muss das gar nicht zusammenkommen
sondern die stille
also wie kann man so wie kann man so
sagen auf den begriff bringen es muss
immer auf derselben die ursachen müssen
immer auf derselben ebene angesiedelt
sein und wie kann man das sich noch ein
bisschen klarer machen also jetzt sagen
möchte
was sollten wir nicht machen was ist
hier die punkte
tatsächlich ist
ok also dass potenzielle wäre dann der
stoff
ein spezielles
wir schauen uns den menschen denn die
ganzen menschen
ursächlich für etwas konkretes
generell grundwissen für
sagt zumindest weil niemand außen suchen
sondern ist alles und gar nicht
aber wenn wir jetzt sagen nein nur sage
ich mal für die möglichkeit eines
tisches generelles praktisch mit der sz
die sind
genau ich denke es um bis zu 1
wir sehen das als eine sehr
differenzierte analyse diesel
verschiedenen kausalen faktoren eben
immer auch hinsichtlich der möglichkeit
und der wirklichkeit und dann
hinsichtlich des allgemeinen dass er von
einer statue allgemein sprechen und von
einer konkreten statue dieser konkreten
staat durch das ist also wichtig was mir
eben jetzt besonders wichtig war war
wenn wir jetzt generell sprechen auf
dieser generellen ebene wie sich dann
die verschiedenen arten sozusagen von
kausalität formlosigkeit stoff
übersichtlichkeit wirklichkeit wie die
eine logik zueinander stehen und ich hab
so den verdacht dass es einen guten
grund hat warum aristoteles in diesem
zitat was wir hier gleich am anfang
hatten warum er hier eben am schluss
hierbei viertens geben vom instinkt
spricht gerade am schluss also mir ich
glaube tatsächlich dass es hier so eine
innere logik gibt die das ganze so zu
einem abstrakten sinne gliedert kegel
würde natürlich gern friedrich hegel
würden natürlich sagen natürlich war es
der aristoteles schon angelegt er hat ja
diese wissenschaften logik entwickelt
für hegel muss sich alles nach einer
gewissen logische notwendigkeit
begrifflich auseinander entwickeln
ich glaube wir haben hier bei
aristoteles schon so ein bisschen was
gesehen weil eben hier die verbindung
beider das zusammenbringen von
möglichkeiten wirklichkeit
offensichtlich mit wirklichkeiten
verbindung gebracht wird und das scheint
nahe zu liegen dass eben die
wirklichkeit eben in der logischen reihe
eben nach der materie nach der stoff
ursache und nach der form und sache erst
kommen weil sie beides zusammen bringt
zum sinn holland
[Applaus]
nicht nur die nur die position im
gefühlt also nicht was wichtiger ist
sondern was wann kommt was welchen
logischen stellenwert und welchen
logische position hat im in der
konstitution im erzeugen im kausalen
multifaktoriellen erzeugen eines
konkreten dingen und jetzt gebe ich noch
einen ganz kurzen überblick oder
einblick ausblick auf die nächste
sitzung wir haben jetzt hier also uns je
durchgequält jetzt mit aristoteles ist
wirklich sehr schwer muss ich wirklich
sagen und die übersetzung ist vielleicht
auch nicht die allerbeste ich schreibe
noch mal eine zusammenfassung wo es noch
mal ein bisschen im kontext versuche
klar zu machen
wir machen jetzt einen riesigen zeitigen
sprung wir lassen jetzt die ganze antike
hinter uns sogar das mittelalter
überspringen wir jetzt einfach von einer
woche auf die nächste
das ist ungeheuerlich und wir kommen der
nächsten sitzung noch mal natürlich
kurzer fahrt des todes zurück aber dann
kommen wir auf david hume zu sprechen
wenn sie meine seminarplan schauen und
david hume ist also klar jedenfalls für
uns und auch unserem heutigen
verständnis vielmehr was kausalität
anbelangt und ich gebe nur einen kurzen
ausblick der mit ihm sagt es gibt so was
wie kausalität gar nicht unter logisch
zumindest können wir es nicht wissen
sondern es sagt kausalität diese
übergang von ursache und wirkung ist
eine reine regula ried wir machen immer
mal wieder die erfahrung dass wenn wir
haben wie folgt das machen wir
tausendmal dav erst kommt dann kommt er
und irgendwann wenn du uns daran gewöhnt
haben dann sagen wir us die ursache und
wirkung und diese kausale relation
dieser übergang von fw ist nicht
irgendwie
eine kraft oder eine logische
existierende nötigung eine kausale kraft
sondern es ist unsere gewohnheit also
dieser übergang dieses fragezeichen da
müssen wir hin strahlt gewohnheit ist es
unsere erwartungshaltung unsere
gewohnheit und vertrauen auf die
vergangenheit was uns zu diesen kausalen
schluss führen und das ist natürlich
eine gänzlich andere art und weise über
kausalität zu reden als es die
vorherigen getan
es ist nämlich eine sehr skeptisch eine
serie puristische weise und es ist eine
sehr subjektive weise über kausalität zu
sprechen und der wird jung wird dann
wiederum der die basis sein für das
auftreten der kausalität theorie bei ihm
an kant der wir aber dann zwei sitzungen
widmen wollen ohne auf die wir erst noch
zu sprechen kommen dann bis zur nächsten
sitzung